remember John Carter the ambitious
sci-fi Odyssey about a Civil War veteran
who gets whisked away to Mars if you
don't you're not alone far fewer people
went to see it than Disney had hoped and
we think we finally know why
let's not mince words John Carter was an
okay movie released in 2012 by Disney
and based on a series of books written
by Edgar Rice Burroughs the same author
whose work led to Disney's Tarzan the
science fiction Blockbuster was intended
to be a box office epic perhaps on the
same level as Star Wars
Captain John Carter
Virginia
[Music]
instead John Carter failed to charm
audiences into spending their
hard-earned cash resulting in an
unprecedented loss for the mouse that
ended up somewhere around 200 million
dollars most of the key elements for a
resounding success were present Source
material from a famous author a popular
genre and a big budget so what happened
here where did the recipe break down
there's no quick answer but the last
decade is seeing a not insignificant
number of theorists taking a shot at a
satisfying solution to one of Disney's
largest failures while various sources
cite different specific causes for the
Cinematic catastrophe it seems as if
everyone agrees that John Carter was
ultimately Dead on Arrival the film
undeniably lacked star power while the
cast boasted the high profile talents of
Mark Strong Willem Dafoe and Brian
Cranston these artists were not cast in
Center Stage roles instead the leads
were given to comparatively unknown
actors Taylor Kish in Lynn Collins of
course bringing in New Or Less know in
town is a good thing but it simply
doesn't lead to financial gain the same
way that leaning on popular familiarity
does if John Carter had been played by
someone like Brad Pitt or Leonardo
DiCaprio things might have gone a bit
differently further the Edgar Rice
Burroughs novels weren't and aren't
Mainstays in the modern Zeitgeist so
when Disney marketed the film by teasing
it during a Super Bowl ad like it was a
long-awaited title viewers were left
scratching their heads for a blockbuster
to function someone in the Forefront of
the mix has to have social currency the
more recent science fiction epic Dune
combated this same issue by Drowning the
material in Celebrity performers a move
that made younger audiences invested in
a story originally written in the 1960s
by comparison John Carter had a far
longer gap between the novel and film
with far less prevalent performers in
its cast
should either of these interwoven
factors be ignored then the final
product has to stand solely on its own
Merit unfortunately for Disney though
John Carter was just okay it's by no
means horrible nor is it exemplary it's
simply adequate this is reflected by its
Rotten Tomatoes score as 52 from critics
and 60 from audiences middling across
the board according to deadline director
Andrew Stanton was overly faithful to
the source material following it so
closely that it may have actually hurt
the finished project the movie was too
similar to the book definitely isn't a
complaint that's heard very often
whether Stanton's Faith to the source
material is indicative of an Earnest
desire to represent the story or a
lackluster creative mind is not clear In
fairness these aren't even the only
option simply the ones that seem most
likely that being said the results of
Stanton's artistic Direction and casting
indicate that regardless of intent a
different leader might have been
required to Shepherd John Carter to
victory for now that's where the story
ends in 2014 Disney lost the rights to
the John Carter franchise preventing any
possibility of a sequel or spin-off the
Edgar Rice Burroughs estate has kept the
property away from other Studios so far
but that doesn't mean they won't try
again sometime in the future it's not
impossible to make John Carter work on
the Silver Screen it simply has yet to
be done
[Music]